おはようございます。
今日のプリティーシリーズニュースをお届けします。
まずは、おねがいアイプリです。
アニメおねがいアイプリ第11話いのりのたからもののあらすじと先行カットが公開されました。
第11話は、もうすぐ誕生日を迎えるいのりを中心にしたお話です。
いのりは自分の誕生日パーティーを開こうと、あおいたちを招待します。
一方で、あおい、ぐみ、おりびあは、いのりへのプレゼントを考えるために、いのりのおじいちゃんとおばあちゃんのもとへ。
そこで、いのりが大好きなお友達と、ずーっと仲良しでいられますようにと願っていたことを知ります。
放送は6月14日朝9時30分から。
公式Xでも予告映像が案内されており、いのりの“たからもの”がどんな形で描かれるのか、注目の回になりそうです。
続いて、キングオブプリズムです。
6月28日に京王アリーナTOKYOで開催されるキングオブプリズム Pretty Boys SPECIAL サンクス PARTY！
とキングオブプリズム SUPER LIVE Prism☆Tours！
について、公式Xで一般販売開始の案内が出ています。
一般販売は6月13日正午12時からスタート。
昼の部はキンツア本編のスペシャル上映イベント、夜の部は約6年ぶりとなるスーパーライブという構成です。
さらに、同イベントのライブビューイングについても新しい案内がありました。
昼の部のライブビューイングでは、入場者特典としてSPECIAL サンクス PARTY！
SePTENTRION ドラマCDが配布予定です。
内容はこの特典のためだけに書き下ろされたストーリーで、SePTENTRIONのメンバーが出演します。
ライブビューイングの一般販売も、6月13日正午12時から先着で開始されます。
今日のプリティーシリーズは、おねがいアイプリ第11話の先行情報と、キングオブプリズム10周年イベントのチケット・ライブビューイング情報が中心となりました。
それでは、今日も素敵なプリティーシリーズライフをお過ごしください。
以上、今日のアイプリニュースでした。